Hey Youtubers it's Charlie and a New Series
8 Trailer just dropped and revealed our old
enemy Davros will return as one of the main
villains this year.
I say one of the main villains because just
because one big bad is coming back doesn't
mean others won't follow.
So this video is going to be a breakdown of
the new footage and my top 5 theories about
how Davros could still be alive.
Hello to any new people, if you're just finding
me for the first time, I'm doing weekly Doctor
Who videos until Series 8 gets here.
I'll be doing a ton of stuff during the season.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
So let's start with the actual footage.
What they've done in the last couple of teasers
is use the same scene from different perspectives.
The TARDIS console erupting in Sparks.
In the previous clip and that first image
they released The Doctor was standing away
from it, but in this he's operating the console.
It's the same basic scene, just a different
moment inside it.
The really interesting part comes after that
first explosion.
If you don't recognize the voice, it's Davros.
I had to listen to it twice because the first
time my volume was turned down and it sounded
like a Dalek.
Daleks have been confirmed for Series 8.
The second time I heard it, the voice was
way too human to be a normal Dalek, and not
high pitched enough.
And I re-listened to a clip from Davros' voice,
here's what the voice in the trailer sounds
like....And here's what Davros' voice sounded
like during Stolen Earth in Series 4.
So yes, Davros is back, we'll talk about the
mechanics of how he's back in a second.
First let's finish talking about what he's
saying to The Doctor.
I see into your soul, I see beauty, divinity,
hatred.
As he's saying these things it looks like
He's scanning the Doctor.
As if he's inside the TARDIS with him.
I don't think this is the case, Davros' voice
sounds so dream-like, I wonder if it's coming
from some sort of netherspace, like when we
heard the Time Lord's voices coming through
the cracks in the Universe in the 50th Anniversary
Special.
Davros sounds like he's speaking from somewhere
far away.
Plus the scan zooms in on the Doctor's Hearts
and his heart beats.
I think a couple of things are going on here.
I don't think Davros is going to try and steal
the Doctor's body parts or anything.
I think he's stuck without a body somewhere,
like outside the Universe.
And he's going to play on the new Doctor's
personality to help him return.
So how is he still alive?
Well technically his final fate was never
confirmed after Journey's End.
In that episode, the meta-crisis Doctor and
Donna were able to destroy the new Daleks
and left Davros on the Crucible which was
burning.
He himself had been enslaved by the Supreme
Dalek and the new Daleks and forced to create
the Reality Bomb.
The Doctor offered to save him but Davros
said no and cursed the Doctor naming him the
Destroyer of Worlds.
It was an interesting twist on the character
since Davros had been such a villain over
the years.
To be fair he started out as more of a misguided
mad scientist.
Not a straight up monster villain.
So it's pretty clear at this point he didn't
die and somehow used the Medusa Cascade to
survive.
Supposedly The Doctor sealed it in Journey's
End, but my guess is that the events of the
50th Anniversary and the cracks in the Universe
allowed Davros to send messages out.
The dreamlike quality of his voice makes it
sound like he's still stuck
in there.
In case you haven't seen any of the episodes
involving the Medusa Cascade it's a rift in
space time.
The Daleks were going to use Davros' reality
bomb to cause an explosion that would travel
from the rift into normal space across all
Universes.
Remember your multiverse theory.
They were trying to make it so they would
be the only race left in existence.
In any universe.
So here are my top 5 theories about how Davros
could return during Series 8.
Number 5 - He could have already used the
cracks in the universe to return and has been
rebuilding his power somewhere quietly since
the 50th Anniversary.
Number 4 - Steven Moffat will bring back the
idea of Dalek Khan's prophecy and interpret
it in a new way.
Davros' speech during Journey's End talked
about looking into the Doctor's Soul.
That was all happening while Dalek Caan was
secretly manipulating events to help bring
about the destruction of his own race.
Number 3 - He rebuilt part of the Crucible
and used it to get out.
It's a simple re-purposing of the machinery.
Number 2 - Davros will use something we haven't
seen yet, an alliance with a new character
to help him get out.
Number 1 - He's still stuck inside the Medusa
Cascade and he's going to play on the Doctor's
personality to trick him into helping Davros
escape.
The master was able to trick the Doctor using
the pocket watch, if he can do it, so could
Davros.
They were just seen filming the final episodes
of series 8 featuring that new character called
The Gatekeeper and loads of Cybermen.
Someone even spotted the head of a classic
Mondas Cyberman on the ground.
So it's possible that Davros could return
right before or during the finale and The
Doctor will get the help of this new character
and the cybermen to help defeat him.
The doesn't look like he's a captive of the
Cybermen in these pictures, that's why I'm
speculating they're helping him.
It could be a situation like 'the enemy of
my enemy is my friend'.
The Daleks and the Cybermen have worked together
in the past, but they're not friendly races.
And Davros' own Dalek creations even betrayed
him during Series 4, so alliances change all
the time.
Now it's your turn let me know how you think
Davros is coming back and do you think Dalek's
Caan's Prophecy will come back into play?
Like I said, I'm doing weekly Doctor Who videos
until series 8 gets here.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Episode 1 is airing August 23rd.
In case you're behind I've been doing a bunch
of series 8 bonus videos.
Click here for my breakdown of the last trailer
and click here to learn what's going on in
all the episodes this season.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!